shadow transport secretary louise hey
representing uh labour this morning with
us here in the studio high so much to
talk about can we can we i know
what else you want to talk about but
let's talk about that first of all these
kids who are here
i mean just absolutely
heartbreaking and emotional as the
doctor just described talking about um
that journey and we've seen
countless examples on the news over the
last few weeks of children in exactly
those circumstances and and that
question you asked about how they chose
which children um were brought over just
goes to the devastation of this war
um unfortunately i think our response as
a country to the refugee crisis the
biggest
refugee crisis in europe since the
second world war has been too slow too
complicated and far too mean and i think
the government needs to urgently step up
is it getting better
i mean we were clearly pleased to see
michael gove's statement yesterday but
it posed far more questions than it
answered i still don't know for example
this morning if i can register for the
website and just say my home is open to
any ukrainian refugee or whether i have
to know one in advance to be able to
nominate them the amount of money for
local authorities is half of what was
available for the afghani refugee crisis
last year
so we're still nowhere near where we
need to be still nowhere near
what as a country i think we would want
to offer because britain has always
stood ready to open its doors its homes
to the health secretary and he he
acknowledged that and i asked him
whether they'd acted quickly enough and
he said we're acting now so you can read
into that what you like there was no
veiled criticism there of the home
secretary but one wonders why michael
gove is now involved what's your take
well indeed and i think most of the
british people would question why um
pretty patel was home secretary and
leading a response to this refugee
crisis she has shown time and time again
um that she does not demonstrate the
principles of the british people and our
priority must be now
to help those in desperate need fleeing
in the very bitter cold the numbers that
we have offered visas to so far are
frankly shameful in response in
comparison to our european allies and i
think it is quite telling that you've
got michael gove and sajdah javid
leading the charge across the airwaves
and frankly taking the policy off her in
government okay it's too late for some
now i don't know whether you've seen
this story i hope that you have already
louise because it is heart-wrenching the
mum who was in mario paul did you see
the story and um she
literally was being stretched out of a
hospital that had been bombed we've
learned
within the last hour or so
that both her and her baby have died i i
i can't even begin to comprehend uh the
images that we're seeing what's your
view
i mean
we saw the attacks last week on the
maternity hospital and the children's
hospital this week when president
zielenski addressed the house of commons
last week he spoke about the children
that had been killed these are
indiscriminate attacks on civilians and
blatant war crimes and there is
absolutely no doubt about that um this
illegal uh crime of aggression is
undeniably a war crime and we believe
there should be a tribunal set up
urgently and immediately in order to
investigate those so that as soon as
possible those responsible can be
brought to justice how concerned is
labour about how close the attack was to
uh the nato border the polish boda
border i did speak to lord dana earlier
and he said we just need to cool our
engines as far as that's concerned
because it wasn't within nato territory
so let's just leave it at that yeah i
mean clearly nato's borders haven't been
breached yet but we stand fully aligned
with the government in its political
economic and military support to ukraine
and we will stand four square with all
our nato allies it is concerning but
it's well above my pay grade to tell you
whether um you know any red lines have
been crossed yet
um we know i was again asking the health
secretary about um the prime minister
going to saudi arabia later on this week
to do a deal as far as oil is concerned
given that we're cutting off energy
supplies with sanctions to to russia and
i did put it to him that really do we
hold our nose and do business with these
people and he said yes we do
well i think this has to be a moment and
a real wake-up call for this government
that we can no longer rely on foreign
oil and gas which is unstable um and
contravenes our values it is shameful
that we're having to have discussions at
the moment about to what extent we
sanction russian oil and gas because we
are dependent on it and a decade frankly
of failing to tackle the challenge of
climate change has left us exposed in
national security terms as well so
rather than running off to other despots
to look at importing oil and gas from
them as well i think we really need to
step up our
commitment to net zero here invest in
renewables insulate those homes we've
got some of the most energy energy
inefficient homes in europe which could
actually reduce our um reliance on
natural gas by 15 percent wiping out the
amount that we import very quickly and
that would um that would actually be a
much quicker response than any of the
other options that the government are
talking about them in the meantime
people
are not going to be able to put petrol
in their cars it's just so expensive and
heat their homes from as early as next
month that's right in two weeks time
people are going to be seeing an
increase of as much as six or seven
hundred pounds um on their energy bills
and the government are completely
missing an action on it either they're
oblivious or they're completely
indifferent and because so far the
measures that rishi sunak has put
forward are like holding a tsunami back
with a sand castle labour have suggested
that we apply a windfall tax to oil and
gas firms who are raking in record
profits at the moment in the words of
one
chief executive of an oil company they
said they have more money than they knew
what to do with that is an affront to
families across this country
i know exactly
exactly when people are as you say
genuinely worrying about cutting back
the essentials thinking about how they
get to work how they feed their families
how they heat their homes and at the
moment the tories are siding with those
oil and gas firms rather than struggling
people across this country good to talk
to you thanks for taking the time thank
you